you can tell me a little bit about your
day today you wake up
Commandments wake up make sure my SARS
are in school
and then Thrive all over creation
looking at these young pretty girls
Instagram Instagram Facebook Facebook
County Jail online
first comes the seduction
then comes the reality after a couple of
days of drinking and smoking now you
gotta go off the street
story about pimps
you think and what they'll do to grab
their share of the billion dollar market
for illicit sex in America
out here in these streets you're either
a predator for your prey you either
sheep or your wolf I'm not saying what
I'll do is right but I'm a wolf out here
is survived on each street because I'm
not going to be no sheep
thank you
[Music]
the very first time I ever did it it was
a complete Rush
and then you just kind of start to get
used to it what is it like when you're
you're out there
it's cold it's really cold
a good amount of clothes we've seen
girls out there in just like a bra and
underwear in the winter in the winter in
the rain a lot of them can't leave until
they're told that they can come back in
my difference
[Music]
you don't know if they're just Gonna
Roll by and just start shooting at you
like a rival pimp that you're working
for someone and that's technically their
enemy so instead of going after the pin
they're gonna go after the girls
how often are you approached spectrums
almost every time we're out there and
you've been doing this for how long
I've been doing this for around three
years
was it soon after you joined the police
department or
um it was a good chunk of time after
[Music]
Michelle as we'll call her is one of two
Oakland police officers who will be
going undercover tonight as decoys so
how do you think we have people very
close
and we do have our firearms
oh you take a gun with you yeah
where does we make it work
sex trafficking has become Front Page
News recently thanks to high profile
cases like that of multi-millionaire
jeffreyevsky for several years Epstein
was operating a sex trafficking ring
not long ago sex trafficking was thought
to be largely a transnational problem
with criminal networks smuggling and
documented women across borders to work
as sex slaves but there's a far more
common variety happening in every U.S
city big and small that sees Americans
exploiting other Americans
no state reports more cases than
California
and by all accounts Oakland is a hot
spot thanks everyone for being here
we're doing a decoy operation today it's
very dangerous for the decoys stay out
of sight keep close if we do arrest a
pimp we're going to call code 3 response
for an arrest
the goal of the operation is to disrupt
business around one of California's most
notorious prostitution tracks
International Boulevard in East Oakland
it's a place where pimps have long been
known to sell underage girls you guys
used to go after mainly the women
working on the streets and you've since
shift and are now going after the
traffickers and the jobs the demand as
well when did that happen October of
last year just October of last year yeah
pretty recent yes pretty recent change
and we want to Target what's fueling the
demand here in Oakland we want to go
after the exploiters the ones that are
victimizing our young women so by
attacking the demand and making people
know that Oakland's not a place that's
going to tolerate forcing people into
prostitution
it's Jimmy beer is the commander of the
vice unit
guide for the evening
when a job pulls up they pull up real
slow kind of to check out the girls see
how they look window shopping I hate to
say pimp on the other hand they want to
make it known they're the big dog in
this neighborhood so they usually swoop
up under the corner really fast anything
intimidating like do a burnout and take
off at a really high rate of speed
yeah that's it right there positive ID
it's happening you see that yeah
the decoys moved several blocks away and
start working on another corner
within minutes the car pulls up please
get out of here
that's him
what do you find with the majority of
these uh Johns what sort of the profile
you see already it's been like one male
Asian one male Hispanic one male black
typically they're being male white next
you know if I'm if I'm gonna bet and
young old married single all of that all
of that yeah there's no real profile of
it John there's a meal
I might have a guy pointing guns at the
prostitutes
quickly it becomes clear that they could
arrest John's all night long
but it's not the Jones they're really
after
we're trying to draw the pimp out lure
him out from behind the Shadows try to
get them to actually recruit one of our
our girls and then we go after them
[Music]
you think they're making more money than
they are if they were selling drugs yes
there's more of it
there's more demand you don't have to
buy the product so I don't have to come
out of pocket I don't have to package it
I'm not being at risk for holding on to
it renewable product that never expires
as long as she's still alive and if
she's alive she better be making money
the challenge is actually finding them
or getting them that's it
our fight against human trafficking is
one of the great human rights causes of
our time and the United States will
continue to lead it we will not rest
until we've stopped every last human
trafficker and liberated every last
survival the fight against trafficking
sends politics
but all of that attention hides an ugly
truth that busting sex traffickers is
extremely difficult in part because
their victims are often afraid to
testify it's more difficult to solve
these cases I would venture to say than
murder charges
for these pimps
a combination that must be irresistible
it's exactly why I want to find one
[Music]
my search begins on Instagram
that's where I learned that pimps have
their own ecosystem of hashtags
there's this one hashtag 304 if you turn
around 304 it actually spells ho
can't show a lot of these faces but
hashtag game related pgo pimp game on
hgo which means whole game on hashtag
izm which is like the Swagger more
jewelry more diamonds this display of
wealth and power these stacks of cash
all of this is just a way to show these
women what their lives could be like if
they were working for them
I have no idea if any of these guys are
actually pimps or just playing the parts
but for some it certainly feels like
their social media feed is the marketing
arm of their operation doesn't seem like
they're very ashamed or trying to hide
what they're doing at all in fact they
want to show it off
over several weeks iMessage countless
guys and a few women asking if any of
them would be up for talking I get
mostly silence
then finally a breakthrough
I stumble upon a genre of book I didn't
know existed the pimp Memoir that's how
I found Mickey Royal
sure enough the author of The Pimp game
agrees to meet me at a motel in the
heart of South Central Los Angeles
[Music]
I'm hopeful that Mickey will be the key
to finding my way inside his former
profession
how are you
Mariana hi Mickey so nice to meet you
same here likewise
I didn't really start really pimping
until I was about 19 or 20. I came from
a drug and gang background so I always
thought of that particular life as being
weak
you know because if it didn't involve a
pistol I wasn't interested but it was
something about
the Allure of it it just sucks you in
and I fell in love with it
more of pimp is no secret now I want you
to get yourself together and get back
out there and get me my money from
movies
to music videos
two seinfelds
very few underworld figures have gotten
as much love from pop culture as
Defender
but I want to know how the business of
pimping really works
Mickey offers to take me for a tour of
the most infamous track in LA
where are we heading are we headed to
Figueroa it's referred to as the track
the blade that's been around since the
60s we're talking about 95 blocks 95
blocks how dangerous is it do you think
it's extremely dangerous it's got the
tricks you have to worry about you have
upset in the pimp you have to worry
about kidnappings stabbing shootings
plenty of them
you're talking about a profession where
sexual assault and rape are just
occupational daily hazards
so I've lived in Los Angeles for over 10
years and I know Figueroa but I've never
seen any of this till tonight that's why
I call it the shadow World it exists at
night and broad daylight she's working
to the right she's wearing a bikini yeah
it's also freezing it's 46 degrees
outside I mean you got to understand if
they have pimps or whatever if they can
make extra money by being seen from a
distance they're not even allowed to
wear jackets see how they both were
naked more than likely they have the
same pound it was that a thing where
your girls I worked with you dress the
same yeah it was easy to shop for all of
them at the same time
so all these three girls have the same
shoes does that mean that they work for
the same hip more than like
she was so young she looked like she was
like 15 or something did you see that
yeah
thousands and dozens and dozens of women
that we've seen so far in what about 20
blocks right right
you see him on Friday and Saturday night
it's like a concert
so where would you be imagine a girl
would be on this corner where would you
be sitting in the car not far away but
I'm not watching her yeah why
to make sure she's okay and I figured
that was my job and if you had more than
one girl how do you cruise around you
might sit here for about 10 minutes
until she gets a day see where it goes
and then you cruise up to see this and
you pull up on one you collect your
money but she's not gonna get these days
while you're sitting there
we've been circling the same stretch of
blocks several times when Mickey gets
spooked
hey that's uh what happened that's it
why what happened well it's starting to
get hot what do you mean what did you do
well we got made as far as the cameras
would have happened is they'll start
telling everybody what they saw and
pointing out the car
you don't want to do that really no you
want to call it a night by now trust me
I follow Mickey's advice but I'm still
hopeful he can connect me to an active
pimp so we've been working on this story
for a long time and it's been really
hard to get people to talk to us
especially people who are currently yeah
you won't get that I mean if you were
currently doing it would you even admit
it to us you hopping out with the
cameras you're better off pulling guns
on me no
girls I'll challenge the camera out the
Run no why not
because if you want to get away with a
crime it has to be a secret
simple as that
start interview Mickey post me a song
he gives me a name a number
and a promise
one phone call later
doors begin to open
[Music]
hi it's Mariana here how are you
Mickey gave me your number and so that
you'd be willing to talk to us we'd love
to meet with you at a place somewhere in
Inglewood if you're available
okay and you're bringing some people
that work with you right right that
hotel is that the place you want to meet
right have you worked out of there
yeah
[Music]
so we've rented this motel room it's a
place that they said they've worked at
before we were supposed to meet here an
hour ago they still haven't showed up
but we're you know we're hoping they
will it's been really hard to get people
to talk to us so it sounded really
positive and I'm hoping that they will
they'll show up tonight foreign
how are you I'm fine come on in
thanks for meeting us here because I
know you guys want us to discuss your
identity so we actually got all these
masks here for you
this morning that's a really pretty one
it's funny because uh when I looked at
them and I was trying to figure out
which one I would wear if it was me I
changed my mind about three times
so we're very close to Figueroa which is
one of the most famous tracks or blades
in Los Angeles have you guys ever been
out there it's a very yes do you think
that a lot of the women that are working
out on the blade the track they all have
pimps I'll say 80 of them do yeah I'll
say yeah did you have a pimp
um when I first started out no I was
just hey let's get away you know what I
mean but I did try it out like guys
wanted me
to beat a hoe and you know I'll hang
around them or kick it with their female
and see how their environment was and it
just wasn't for me it was a lot of
violence it was a lot of Jesse Yeah I
didn't see where the money was going
why do you think other women do it then
daddy issues seeking attention might
have been molested might feel that they
need to be valued by a man and I really
know they value for themselves
there's a lot of people that grow up in
broken homes I'm not having my father
figures like a huge part in the young
girl's life when you don't seek and get
that love that you deserve it pushes you
to a whole another state that you can't
really explain or describe you just feel
the pain do you think that the bimps
know that and they exploit that they go
after those that's how they get you to
never leave and that's why most girls
that's my age they get stuck
they live like that for a very long time
the more we talk the more I realize how
many different ways women are pulled
onto the streets
this is a woman we'll call B
prostitution is not her day job just
something she does after her shifts as a
nurse after school
so it was like I'm doing it anyway
why not I mean I'm not afraid I'm not
ashamed of it so it's like it ain't no
need to be shame everybody having sex
don't you ever fantasize about being a
stripper yeah see this is the part where
I'm not sure if I should be nodding or
not exactly
honey says she works primarily with
clients from the business world
I'm very high price I mean I make a lot
of money doing what I'm doing
she says she can make as much as twenty
thousand dollars a week
but all that money comes at a high
personal cost
so I had a friend and her father he was
a drug dealer and a camp my mother was
never around so I always spent a lot of
time in her house and her dad you know
he was always hit on me and touched me
but I never told me like I didn't have
anyone around so how old were you
um I was 12. I'm sorry if I'm going to
ask you this and tell me if you don't
want to answer or if you don't even want
the question we can take it out but did
he rape you
yesterday
when you were 12 yeah
[Music]
and then how did it progress from there
you told me like it's okay if you do it
for me I'm not going to judge you know
it's going to judge you don't tell
anybody so you know always kept it a
secret like no one ever knew what I did
and how did he convince you that you
should be selling your body out on the
to other men I don't have a mother and a
father around so I grew up thinking that
it was okay you know to sell my body I
was young I was naive like you tell me
it's okay and I just believed you he was
a pimp yeah he had several women working
for him yeah how many I'm about five of
us all of them as young as you yeah
so they were all between 12 12 to like
13 not older than that after four years
honey finally escaped
did he do it anytime in jail or anything
no I'm personally try to do nothing like
that I just wanted to get away one of
the things that we hear a lot is how
women that have pimps even when they're
abusive they just don't want to talk to
the police they don't want to testify
they just want to leave that behind
snitches get stitches so if you tell
people will put a bounty on your head
and they don't care how much it costs
right that's that's what they say
meaning that they will beat you up if
you talk and they'll do it they'll make
sure it gets done once you in it it's
hard to escape it's always going to come
back to you
Once you turn a good girl bad it's hard
to turn back good
after the interview
she makes some introductions I trade
some texts and it looks like it's all
about to happen
until it doesn't
we've been in three different locations
so far just today alone waiting for
these fins to show up
they tell us they're coming they tell us
they're on their way we get everything
set up and we wait and wait and wait and
then last minute they either don't show
up or the tax is telling us they can't
come or they are you know unsure whether
we're police and they don't feel
comfortable
he just failed he's not coming anymore
we actually just got a text from this
one guy uh who says he's on 54th and
Western he's on the corner he told us
he'd be waiting for us we have no idea
what we're walking into who we're
meeting with exactly but we're hoping
that at least there's somebody there
the process is frustrating
I've had easier times getting access to
Gun Runners and drug lords
but I'm realizing this black market is
different
and darker
okay
so this is it we're on a parking lot of
uh laundromats
this is where you told us to meet him
no surprise he's not there
it could be that he's just looking at us
from somewhere and checking us out to
make sure there were knockouts in which
case it might be a good idea if I get
out of the car and just go walk around
and tell him I've been a woman with a
red vest or something
what's that
no taking pictures of me
they're filming me
[Music]
yeah I don't know I mean I think camera
is down for now because they're getting
more and more upset
okay come around the corner to 1609
okay we've got an address
on Western we turn into a residential
neighborhood and make our way to the
address
finally after months of trying here I am
looking into the Dark Shades of a
working pen
[Music]
after months of trying I'm finally face
to face with a working pen
he wants me to call him chill
and this is his business partner lady p
I know that when we were texting back
and forth you were
you didn't want to give us the right
address immediately so you weren't sure
if we were police essentially absolutely
because of the business that we're in if
you're even claiming that you're in this
part of the business they've changed
so now instead of just some regular
we're pimping this pimping no what we're
doing now is considered human
trafficking and that is completely
different from what pimping is so tell
me what is pimping about
about choice
just to see the flash they see the gold
they see the money they see the cars
every time you turn on the radio what do
you hear oh it's some rapper dude
talking about how you got a bunch of
and all this other
so what do they want they want that
rapper dude they see the Ferrari the
Lamborghini all that
they want that what's next to a rapper
a pimp why not he can get you everything
he wants easy
drug sex rock and roll that's what it is
that may be the way pimps like chill
view the lifestyle
but I imagine the reality is far more
complicated for the women working for
him
how do you find the Girls Club AC is
hanging out wearing a VIP section and
we're drinking and we're having fun of
course they don't want to be sitting
over there with normal people They want
to come to the VIP hey girl you want to
come back with us who says that I do
they come back
they see the glitch the glamor the gold
the cards right they want to smoke weed
through Power ecstasy we have on it
around
couple of days after they've been there
okay now you got to come up with some
money Bill's gotta get paid
you got a choice at that point you can
say I'm cool get them out
99.9 of the time
these young gonna be like hey
I got weed I got ecstasy I got
everything I want and I can get some
money out of it
why not is it really that high like that
amount of girls it's not like you're
going out looking for the classiest
females you know you with the ones that
are turned up or it keeps looking over
at us
and watching this you've already been
spotted
foreign
and at that point the choice is made
Jill says that his women
to find their customers online where
they can charge a higher price
so when people call you a sex trafficker
or a human trafficker what do you think
of that I think
if you go talk to my and ask
them what they think am I sex
trafficking they'll be like he's
trafficking me
of Vegas do you do that you transport
them I don't transfer I buy them a
ticket
here go to the airport get out playing
see ya when they come back I'm gonna get
a hit on my cash after this and I'll be
like 16.
[Music]
it's shocking how little is known about
the underground sex economy
one recent study estimates that illicit
sex in the U.S brings in 5.7 billion
dollars a year through Street
prostitution online escort services
residential brothels and massage parlors
but there's no reliable data about how
many pimps and traffickers are operating
or how many victims may be out there
it's rare to get an inside look at a
pims operation which is why I want to
see others
over the next week I connect with two
more pimps who are currently in the game
at a cheap motel in Inglewood I meet
jackknife
and after a bit of convincing I sit down
with Gotti late nights at a bar near the
airport
so these women that you meet them on the
street or how do you recruit them how do
you get them to work on the street nine
times out of ten sometimes Instagram you
know what I'm saying sometimes Facebook
it depends
when you go anywhere anyway
what do you say
to them how you doing beautiful you
might find out what you want to shop and
um we could talk and get to know each
other we hang out with your friends and
talk about how we can make money
yeah
if they want to
go along with the situation they go do
this you butter them up or the butter or
nothing I got to tell them they're
pretty so they can get out there and get
this money they got to be out here with
a big head so they can get out there and
get this bread
is there a particular kind of girl that
you're looking for somebody that's not
showing fear
ready to go
an easy target would be um let's say jam
Brady if you're familiar with the Brady
one she's the middle child and she's the
one that gives the least amount of
attention she's the one that feels the
most unattractive I would show Jen the
majority of the attention and point out
how Jan is much prettier than her sister
Marsha and Jan but she leaves my
presence she goes back to being ugly in
that house
so her self-esteem her sense of
empowerment her will to be number one or
the fact that she is number one is only
present when I'm around so she's going
to be around me more and more
I tried to thin them down on the
financials of their business
but they're evasive
I'll say about seven six is the lowest
eight or nine at the most right now I've
got four these four girls work full time
for you yes they're only for me
and each takes a certain percentage of
the earnings do they keep the majority
or do you guys keep the majority you
guys keep the majority if I'm taking
care of you I have to keep the majority
absolutely can you tell me what the
percentage is
it a higher percentage for them or for
you for me it's my money it's our money
this is an awkward thing so yeah of
course you're gonna get some money I'm
gonna break you off something I wanna go
buy you something or whatever you ain't
gonna get no money every single time
it's crazy to me a woman sells her body
and these pimps feel entitled to the
prophets
and we're talking serious money here a
justice department study found that pims
can make between five and thirty
thousand dollars a week it's no surprise
how some of them maintain control have
you ever beat your woman
um
take that as a yes then
what leads a person to do that what led
you
in my case might be stolen
if they get out of line if they look
like they finna say something stupid not
not slapped up you might get punched up
whatever
might cut you whatever have you done
that me female ran away once or twice
I cut the bottom of her foot
you cut with a bottom of her foot not
with no knife I cut the bottom of her
foot with a razor with a razor what is
she running away for what is you doing
you got my money and all that what you
trying to do bribe me no what is you
doing when I did that
that let all the know so I
didn't have to do that no more so if
they want to leave you don't let them
leave they can leave they can leave
because I'm not holding you I'm not
holding you at gunpoint you're not but
you've admitted I don't have your
handcuffed you say it's a choice for
them but yeah
after you just told me what you did I'm
sure they're scared to death I'll leave
them if you could still leave I told her
I just told her if you leave you're
gonna remember me though
but is she still with you yeah she's
still living she still works for you to
this day
you understand it's either you're gonna
with me and you're not it's so
sweet hold on it's pimps out here doing
way work today
killing out here
kidnapping for real time but
no you can't go nowhere against your
will don't talk to your family or
none of that it's bad out here
the reality is Bleak and all too common
but there are people out there trying to
make a difference
you can hold the cameras because it's
right in front of us
I'm in Los Angeles not that far from
where I live trying to understand how
pimps justify what they do
I think people listening to this would
say that what you're doing is exploiting
women when they're at their worst of
their worst you either stay and you have
a place to stay and you go out on the
streets and sell your body or we're
going to kick you out isn't that an
exploitation we're not out there beating
on these females choking them out
getting them started on drugs we don't
have a white van we're not about to pull
up and kidnap you
you can always leave it could be worse
you could choose worse
experts believe that the majority of the
young women pimps and traffickers
as high as 60 or 70 percent have spent
time in the foster care system
it's a crime that preys on the most
vulnerable
nobody cares about them
they're viewed as the rejected and
that's what makes it so easy for pimp to
recruit them I love you
I love you your mother doesn't love you
because she put you out your Daddy
doesn't love you because he molested you
in the first place I love you
if you haven't had something and you're
experiencing it for the first time
and it's beautiful you'll take it even
if it's ugly
which part of it is ugly
you tell I'm telling your body
[Music]
but you still said yes
again it's a choice I mean but is it a
choice it is it is
we'll always have a choice everyone has
a choice
chill for sex trafficking has
of that he used horse fraud or coercion
to induce a woman into selling her body
that's a difficult challenge especially
when pimps like chill nowhere the legal
lines are drawn
I imagine that's why he and Lady P are
so fond of that word choice
still these days pimps know they have
Targets on their backs
they just might be surprised by some of
the people trying to hunt them down
why don't you want to be on camera
for security reasons
we are gathering evidence against people
who may in fact be criminals and who may
in fact end up on a district attorney's
Target list because of us and I wouldn't
want them to come back and try to kill
me
because these are dangerous people these
are dangerous people that we're dealing
with
Jenna as I'll call her is a successful
Tech entrepreneur
s used zip codes well say to our donors
you know what we can do this we have an
established track record of success we
can find kids for under twenty thousand
dollars I mean what would you rather
have another diamond bracelet on your
wrist or would you rather be able to
actually find a girl who's missing and
savor
that's the mission of Special Operations
the non-profit Jenna found it
there's no shortage of groups like hers
who have taken up the cause of sex
trafficking
but Special Operations is more
aggressive than most
it not only rescues girls in trouble it
also goes after their traffickers
Special Operations is designed to fill
in the gaps in society in order to solve
sex trafficking crimes
the way the system works right now the
national Center for missing an exploited
children sends law enforcement half a
million tips hilarious of sex
trafficking hotlines sends thousands of
tips they can be months old by the time
they land in somebody's file folder
Jenna has connected me to her lead
investigator a former cop named Mike
Ferrari how long have you been after
this guy it's been on and off for about
a year
I only have dejola Mark I don't have
visual subject
Mike's team which consists of three
other private investigators each in
their own car is currently working a
case involving a man we'll call Rey
it has a history of trafficking miners
we know this guy is a Serial Predator
we've been trying to develop a pattern
on him to find a location where there
certainly are their victims because each
time there was an arrest me there was
more than one victim how many girls does
it believe that he has working for him
we know three discreet victims that
we've spoken with
um
but each one of them has talked about
multiple girls but one time when one of
the 15 year olds was recovered there
were three other girls at that time
as is so often the case though the
victims were too scared to testify
against him
I've got the back entrance
when he does somebody get on foot
to let us know which way he goes out of
the courtyard
[Music]
Rey is expected to appear in court today
for an unrelated charge
looming he shows up Mike and his team
will use the opportunity to hop on his
tail Mike is convinced that Rey is still
trafficking
but they need evidence
any new information this guy
will help the part of the purpose of our
organization is to
work on guys that do slip through the
cracks
so they have eyes on him there now
okay here he is that's him right there
in that corner
be careful with the cameras yeah
yeah it's great discreet but he didn't
see us
yes Mark's to your right
here I got him he's about to drive past
me
going to the red lights left and right
here
okay stay with them
stay with him
I'm in the Bay Area embedded with a team
of private investigators chasing a
suspected trafficker from the get-go
he's acting suspicious flying down the
highway before the pan recipe is right
in front of weaving through
neighborhoods
man I need somebody here now guys
he finally pulls into a house not far
from Stanford University but the Pi's no
well from previous surveillance
to Grandma's house grandma's house
grandma's house
the day is spent keeping track of his
movements where does he go who does he
see who else might he be working with
already there is a new car that we
haven't seen before so it looks like he
got some activity
traffickers are known to move victims
between different counties and even
states to keep them disoriented and to
keep law enforcement guessing
this guy he reports one address in the
county across the bay one address in the
South Bay he acquires the victims in
another County so he got multiple
jurisdictions involved you can have
something happening on one side of the
bay and then really what maybe four or
five miles between the two but there's
no communication between law enforcement
and sometimes Judicial System itself so
that makes it really hard to catch guys
like this yes
building a real case against Rey will
take more missions like this one if
successful Mike will then hand over his
findings to law enforcement with the
hopes they'll open their own
investigation
but there's no guarantee
and all of this is to try and stop just
one of the countless pimps and
traffickers out there
still Jenna is convinced
this is a crime that money and a good
Network can actually solve maybe that's
a bit of Silicon Valley optimism
or maybe it's the truth but in thinking
about money and resources and the Ugly
business of trafficking there are other
truths to consider too
as crazy as these pimps and prostitutes
are
they don't cross King Boulevard
once you cross King Boulevard you cross
into money
to the north of King lies the campus of
USC
with its nearly six billion dollar
endowments to the south of King it gets
rough quick that looked like someone had
Dropped a Bomb on it like a little war
torn
for Mickey this divide explains
everything about where you end up in
life
geography as destiny
to be growing up in a certain area where
we ain't got no resources we ain't got
nothing we can't do this and that like
certain other races can in their areas
there ain't no jobs around you got a
whole Community that's not getting hired
and you got a lot of that's like what we
gonna do
I grew up around gang bangers pimps at
15 you're not thinking about it like
that but then I was in your face and
you're like why not
my brother was a gun and so you just
grew up I grew up with it yep it was a
lot of paper going on people in your
family a couple of guys in my family
grew pants
so you think if you grew up in another
neighborhood in another city it'd be
totally different I grew up with
everybody around pants gangbangers
thieves murderers jackers all these it's
like one Boiling Pot it's real loud here
that I grew up I thought that was right
I've seen as I'm growing up
I'm a kid
and I got people telling me it's wrong
but they got the money though how can I
get this money it's a situation but it's
a Hustle
I make no excuses for these things
but I understand Jack Knight's
frustration
it must be hard growing up adjacent to
so much wealth and having so few options
but what makes pimping different than
other hustles
is that people's lives are in the
balance
most often young women coming from their
own difficult circumstances so I'm
actually surprised when Jill agrees to
let me sit down with one of the women
who works for him
when did you start escorting about when
I was 15 and I fell into the wrong guy
and it was horrible and then I met you
at a bar and he just seemed like a nice
guy he is so sweet honorable he's always
a man of his word he does exactly what
he said he's going to do he believed in
my dreams and he's just like oh like I
can help you and he just started helping
me I quickly realized that something
feels off he never did me and he just
kind of took me in it's the most glowing
review of a pimp you could ever imagine
do you give him part of your money
though
um yes but it's just the same as putting
the money into my bank just like I said
you would take your card out and make a
web job only mine it's not a card it's a
person so he's your family I wouldn't
call him myself because he's sweet he's
very honorable you don't like to come to
him what do you call him my friend and I
realize I have no idea how many of these
details are true and how many of them
are simply talking points to please her
boss
who spends the entire interview looming
over us with a pool stick in his hand
that's the tricky thing about doing
these sex trafficking stories
when you drive down the street like
Figueroa or International Boulevard and
you see the women working it's
impossible to know their realities
some of them are out there by choice
but some of them are not
some of them are like honey do you ever
get angry knowing that there's men right
now all over the city all over the
country doing to women what you're
tempted to you
yes in my case a 12 year old for one
they don't know what's best for them at
the time but I'm looking at an adult who
can potentially guide me in the right
direction but I was guided in the wrong
direction so it always crosses my mind
like if I never got introduced to this
type of Lifestyle how would I be living
or will my life be like or how would I
be would I be different would I still be
the same like I just feel sorry for the
females on 39 still going through the
same thing because
it's like it's just destroying a woman's
whole life
[Music]
oh
I'll get it
now and I'm like to the point where I
have a child of my own and I had to make
sure that I have more than enough for
her because I only give her the world
you know because she deserves it you
know she didn't ask to be here I brought
her here
so I've been reading your book and I've
been taking some notes Here
I hope to a pimp is worth nothing she is
actually worth everything you take away
everything she has and then give her
what she needs you the pen are the cause
as well as the solution to all her
problems you give her the poison then
sell her The Cure
so this is something you that's actually
true camping is premeditated you know
exactly what you're doing and you know
the long-term effects of it you have to
be a sadist because you have to enjoy
what you're doing and you know good and
well what you're doing
you know good and well with you
[Music]